Et bien tout d’abord, merci à tous d’avoir répondu présents à mon appel.
C’est bien normal.
-Pas de quoi.
Gurlu
C’est bon, vous allez pas commencer à faire vos lèches-culs.
Pardon?
Excusez-moi j’ai un petit problème avec l’autorité.
Ah, rapport à la grande guerre.
C’est vrai que vous en aviez pris plein la gueule.
C’est juste que j’aime pas qu’on me donne des ordres, c’est tout.
Ah, vous êtes un genre d’indépendantiste.
-Voilà.
Ou un gros con.
-Quoi?
Bon, s’il vous plait, on a du boulot.
Je disais, merci à tous d’être venus
Mais de rien.
Et nous allons enfin pouvoir régler ensemble la question des humains.
Pff, encore?
Ah, si j’avais su…
Gurlu
Excusez-moi mais on n’avait pas déjà réglé le problème?
Je croyais qu’ils étaient pas assez évolués ou je sais pas quoi.
Oui, enfin, cela dit quand on vous voit,
on peut se reposer la question.
Mais la question justement c’est qu’ils commencent vraiment à avoir des doutes.
Donc pour la énième fois, qu’est-ce qu’on fait des humains?
Gurlu?
Ouais ou alors on détruit la Terre.
Oui, bien sûr, c’est bien, allons-y en finesse pour une fois.
Ça dépend, ils sont combien?
Environ 7 milliards.
(rires)
On peut se permettre un petit sacrifice.
Gurlu.
Attends, on va pas commencer à parlementer pour 7 milliards, si?
Non mais attendez, il n’a jamais été question de détruire la Terre, hein.
Ça aurait réglé le problème assez rapidement je pense.
Déjà, qu’est-ce qu’on sait d’eux?
Alors, apparemment,
certains d’entre eux croient en une espèce de barbu cosmique,
qui ferait des choses extraordinaires,
mais comme ils sont pas d’accord sur le sujet ils se foutent sur la gueule.
Sur la même planète?
Ils sont complètement cons ou quoi?
Qui c’est qui leur a mis ça en tête?
Pardon,
j’avoue le barbu c’est ma faute.
Mission d’infiltration qui a mal tourné.
Comment je pouvais savoir qu’ils marchaient pas sur l’eau moi?
Et ben voilà, l’infiltration. Ça, c’est une bonne idée!
Ça nous permettra de vérifier leur évolution depuis la dernière fois.
Alors qui veut y aller?
Gurlu.
Attendez, faites pas vos timides, c’est un peu comme prendre des vacances.
Des vacances? Non mais t’as vu les engins qu’ils se trimballent là-bas?
On peut pas faire deux mètres sans se faire tirer au cul.
Sinon y’a Roswell.
Il est jamais revenu Roswell.
Ah.
Oui, ben oui, du coup, pas Roswell.
Eh.
-Quoi?
Bob il arrête pas de lire dans mes pensées là.
-N’importe quoi.
Mais si.
-Oui, mais ça a pas dû prendre longtemps.
Un truc qui va pas prendre longtemps c’est ma main dans ta gueule.
Bon, calmez-vous.
Y’en a pas un pour rattraper l’autre là.
vous êtes censés être l’élite de la galaxie, vous comprenezça?
Et là, y’a personne pour faire avancer le débat.
Gurlu.
Euh, non. Par contre, moi j’ai une idée,
pourquoi est-ce qu’on téléporterait pas un humain.
C’est une idée de con.
-Ça c’est une bonne idée.
C’est une idée de moi.
Taisez-vous.
Ça c’est bien. Qu’est-ce qu’on lui demande après?
Ben, on lui demande de défendre, selon lui,
les valeurs de l’espèce humaine voir s’ils méritent vraiment de vivre.
D’accord mais à ce moment-là on choisit un homme ou une femme?
Gurlu.
Non mais on a qu’à prendre quelqu’un au hasard, pour pas être influencés.
Et ben voilà, excellente idée.
Bon, ben si ça va à tout le monde, vous êtes prêts?
C’est parti.